so the myth that all nate freaks have
ocd is a common one
most people who are clean just actually
care about being clean and that's
totally
different than having ocd also there are
no five stages of loss it's just a myth
that's laura goran one of three
psychologists we brought into our
studios
to debunk some of the most common mental
health
myths so the myth that most people with
schizophrenia have multiple
personalities that was a very old
way that it was understood and it's been
proven to not be true
so with with schizophrenia it's not
another personality what it is though
is a break with reality and a part of
ourselves maybe for instance that
believes
that someone is out to get them okay so
that's a really common one with
schizophrenia
so the myth that all nate freaks have
ocd is a common one
it seems like it's almost a popular
cultural thing that people say to each
other you have ocd when somebody is like
organizing their bag
and in reality ocd itself the the
illness has
different components and one of the
subsets is
the the keeping things organized and
clean but it has to be
at an obsessive level where people are
thinking about it all the time
and so that itself is really uncommon
most people who are clean just actually
care about being clean and that's
totally
different than having ocd bipolar
disorder is not simply mood swings
it's a very high elevation of maybe a
positive mood in a very low
negative mood everybody has mood swings
but with bipolar disorder it's not just
that
it's you know severe forms of you know
elevated mood or depressed mood and
they cycle through that and so sometimes
it could be shown as
symptoms of like a manic episode might
be somebody like hypersexuality or not
sleeping at all and things like that
it's not simply feeling good
this is a common myth and i hear people
throw this one around a lot too
anxiety itself is thinking thinking
thinking and
just imagine yourself going into the
worry thoughts of what if what if what
if this happens what if that happens
and it's unremitting and it goes on for
hours for some people sometimes it's
more
passing for others but being stressed
out about something
as humans we're wired to be to handle
stressors and we've been dealing with an
onslaught of stressors since the
beginning of time
you know going to work taking the subway
coming into contact with other people
you know that that can be stressful that
can be stress inducing
unless you have an actual like panic
attack while you're taking the subway
that would be more of an anxiety
reaction whereas the stress of taking
the subway is more stress-based
you know everybody feels anxious let's
say before presentation or
you know before an exam but an anxiety
disorder
is the extreme form of that where it
becomes you know
it interferes with somebody's daily
functioning this is actually a really
important
myth sadness is an ephemeral reaction
to something it's an emotion by by
definition lasts a few seconds
it can last like 10 minutes but on
average we have an emotion
it passes and then we have another
emotion the thing that tends to bring us
from
sadness to depression is rumination
which means thinking and thinking and
thinking about the thing over and over
and over again
and that's how we then go from sadness
to depression but it's not an immediate
thing we all have
moments of sadness and we just we just
allow them and let them
pass we tend to be okay but if we get
caught up in getting ruminating and
thinking
about all the reasons why we're sad
that's when we tend to go into
depression so
to the myth that depression is not a
real illness it is a real illness and in
fact it can be
incredibly debilitating in order to
classify as having depression we have to
have some kind of a
lethargic kind of behavior where we have
trouble getting out of bed
i mean there are different there are
different ways of depression but one of
the primary ones is
has this kind of what they're called
neuro-vegetative symptoms like where we
can't sleep where we can't eat
there's also a kind of depression which
is dysthymia which
has an anhedonia component into it which
means less pleasure in things that we
used to enjoy which is another kind of
depression and a lot of people will
describe
like oh i used to love pottery and now i
can't even like
i can't even look at pots you know like
something just totally changes for them
when they're deeply in this in this
state of depression
talking about painful things that you've
learned how to sort of cover
over can initially be more painful
but in the interests of working out
things that
if not dealt with straightforwardly are
going to come back to bite them
i'll say another thing about that is
that sometimes
patients wonder what's the therapist
going to feel
if i say thus and so like can the
therapist handle
the level of despair that i sometimes
feel and
on those occasions when the patient has
the strength
to put it out there and see how the
therapist
responds the fact that the therapist can
can handle it
is a big step toward the patient then
being able to handle it
there are reasons and they may change
over time
but i think the thing that i would want
to debunk in that respect
is the idea that there's a single reason
so that if you if you handle that then
you're going to be freed of that and
there's
there's not in most cases there's not
you've got to discover the reasons and
the plural that you're depressed and
what you can do something about
and what you can't the myth that only
women get depressed couldn't be further
from the truth
however women are twice as likely to
experience depression
so the reason why oftentimes people
think women have a higher
rate of depression than men is because
of maybe hormonal changes
life circumstances and stress the other
thing that i like to think about is
that women might express their feelings
in a different way than men do so
sometimes men might you know act out
behaviorally whereas women might focus
on their
internal experience and so they might be
more likely to see a therapist if that's
the case
when people have gone down the road of
eventually deciding to
go on medications for antidepressants
they don't change your personality they
change the symptoms of depression
they can also work for anxiety so
typically if we have
just typical symptoms of depression and
anxiety we'll be given an
antidepressant as what is called an ssri
and that will
help us regulate the symptoms of our
just up and down of moods and the way i
describe it to people is it's like
going back to your baseline you when
it's the right medication
but it doesn't change your personality
your personality your you
so in terms of the myth that will always
be cured
from depression by antidepressants the
research shows that
the most effective thing right now for
depression is actually
therapy and then for people who need
antidepressants therapy
and antidepressants together are another
effective form
and it doesn't not everybody has to take
it so even with people who are taking
antidepressants it's important to still
be in therapy
the myth that bad parenting causes
mental illness i think is a trap
because parents are all too ready to
take responsibility and to feel guilty
about
all sorts of problems that their
children have so there's no point
in reinforcing that and
harming and damaging the mental health
of parents
if you think that your parents caused
your mental illness you're going to end
up
endlessly complaining about your parent
what can you do about the way you were
raised
you can do something about what it's
left you with
in the present around lgbt adults and
youth there's so many myths associated
with with
um mental health and and a big part of
it i think is
unfortunately because the profession
that i'm in had a really dirty history
along these lines and that in the dsm
which is our diagnostic statistic manual
until 1973 homosexuality was actually
listed
as as a disorder and
after a lot of pushback and studies and
and lgbtq kind of rights being
integrated into into theory we realize
that that was really outdated and
since then in dsm-3 it stopped being
and unless somebody has specific anxiety
related to being gay then
they're not diagnosed ever with a mental
health related disorder
associated with it the same is true for
being trans actually
that um it's only if somebody has what's
called like dysphoria where they
they don't like their body that they
then have a diagnosis but just being
trans in
and of itself isn't a disorder anymore
you know to the question about what role
mental health
plays in the attacks of gun violence
unfortunately that's been a
mischaracterization of people who have
severe mental illness is that they're
more likely to commit
crimes and with guns it's not that
people with mental illness are more
likely to be aggressive it's
the people who commit these crimes have
access to guns
and they tend to be really self-loathing
like that's kind of the primary thing
that makes people have a lack of empathy
that seems to be the things that make
them
be more violent and aggressive those are
better predictors than any type of
mental health disorder
people talk about a whole town like on
the news the whole town was traumatized
by
the shooting for instance right and it
doesn't work that way and that's
actually
one of the most common mental health
disorders that i've seen
mischaracterized in that particular way
is ptsd people seem to think that by
virtue of having
experienced a potentially traumatic
event that you'll have these particular
realm of symptoms
that include hyper vigilance there's
impulsivity
there's so many different realms of what
comes up for people after
trauma and i've heard people say you
know because i was traumatized because i
was
there on 9 11 for instance well a whole
city was there we have
really good numbers about the number of
people who ended up having ptsd and
they're actually really
small when something like this happens a
major tragedy like a gun shooting or
a you know 911 or any other type of
tragedy like that
people tend to be resilient there's a
big myth actually even within the mental
health field
saying that there are prototypical ways
to respond to
grief and loss and that's in pop culture
as well that people have these ideas
that
there's one way to grieve and if we're
not devastated and deeply traumatized
that somehow
we're in denial or unfeeling
and that's not true in fact since the
beginning of time we've been dealing
with death we
have different ways of dealing with it
and sometimes sometimes we're relieved
that the person dies because we didn't
have a very good relationship with them
or even if the person if we love them
and we feel really connected to them but
they were sick we're relieved that
they're dead because we don't want them
to suffer anymore
people tend to feel really guilty about
being relieved after a death which is a
very
common reaction to death there are no
five stages of loss it's just a myth
and it's one of the most popular myths
out there
and it's one of those things where
people who aren't very psychologically
minded will come in and say
oh my gosh i must be in the denial phase
of loss or i must be in this phase
because i'm not
you know i'm not dealing with it yet in
reality i just think it's one of those
things that makes us feel safe
like if we can imagine these stages are
ahead of us then we can feel better
about where we are and so i think that's
why it's so popular
however i've seen the flip side which is
why it can be damaging when people have
losses and they're judging themselves
for
not having this prototypical series of
of
stages and they're not based on reality
or evidence or anything
okay so people are going to hate me for
saying this but
and this is so common in the dating
world
like people if you ever look on people's
profiles on dating profiles they always
say like i am an nyf beer i don't even
know what they
say but it's always about how how there
are these certain
you know myers-briggs score and it's
really popular these days myers-briggs
and in fact a lot of organizations use
it and really you know base a lot of
their testing on it
again there's no validation around any
of these
studies and so while it might resonate
for people and that is something that
you know just like when we talk about
you know i'm a i'm a gemini because i do
this you know it resonates for you the
idea of being a gemini
and you might act in ways that remind
you of this description of what it is to
be a gemini but there are no empirical
tests to say that you are
such this thing there are personality
tests but myers-briggs isn't one of them
the myth
that therapy is going to be exclusively
about the past or predominantly
about the past and not help you in your
current
life or not give you a form for talking
about what's happening today and
yesterday
there's a reason why people hold on to
that myth and the reason is
that there was a an early version of
psychoanalysis that
held to the idea that people's
personalities were formed in their first
five years
and that the past was strongly formative
of the present it sometimes can be
helpful to say that there was a pattern
that was established in relation to
people in the past and that can give you
some perspective on what's happening in
the present so
making reference to the past is not
necessarily a bad thing
but it should never be because this
happened
therefore you're having this problem now
it's not an explanation
it's only a way of getting perspective
on the present i think oftentimes people
might say oh
why not go speak with a friend who's a
good friend and they can keep things
confidential
but therapists are trained to work in a
particular way to help people
deal with specific problems they're
facing therapists are
different than friends because even
though your friends might
be willing to for example hold a secret
therapists
really treat things in a very
confidential manner and they're willing
to explore things that maybe a friend
would be uncomfortable exploring
actually the fact is that most people
who come to therapy
are among the stronger people and the
reason is because they have the courage
and the the strength to look at
themselves which is not an easy thing to
do
in various ways i think it's because the
people who come to me
are people who've already decided to
work on themselves good therapists don't
force their patients to talk about
something they don't want to talk about
to the contrary i think that even
encouraging a person to talk about
something that they're not ready to talk
about is counterproductive
the problem with hitting pain points
right on the head
is privacy for one thing people are
entitled to their privacy
therapy isn't just an opportunity to
spill
so i think having people's privacy when
their privacy is respected that makes
them more confident to open up actually
but the other problem for that is that
the therapist needs to be thinking
that there's a limit to the tolerance of
everybody
including the therapist for how much
pain they can
tolerate at any given time and so
respect
for people's anxiety about getting into
some of the more difficult things in
their lives is also part of the process
psychiatrists are the only ones who are
able in this country to prescribe
medication they do us what's called a
psychopharmalogical consult where they
will go through all of your history and
that's something they do
if you want that and i say if you want
that because it's really important
as a psychologist for instance we always
try therapy first it's like it's the
treatment of preference for all
clinicians in fact
they've done all these studies that have
shown that therapy first for several
months before you then even think about
a medication is the best course of
treatment for people
because that way you can really see what
is what and if you then
still want to do medications it's
certainly something you can talk about
but
but you don't have to do medications
it's up to you and your therapist
to if if it feels like that would be
beneficial to you i
i would not say that most therapists
consider
that therapy has to go on forever but i
think when you're interviewing somebody
and considering them
to be your therapist that's one thing to
ask about
how do you think about how long this
should go on
and when do you start to think that
maybe it's time to end it how do you
break up with your therapist
do not break up with your therapist in
an email or a text or a phone message
you've got to be direct you've got to
say i've been thinking that maybe it's
time for us to stop
but then that can't be the end of it if
you haven't already said it
hopefully you have already said it in
one way or another in the preceding
sessions
what i've been looking for is this and i
see how it's been happening
in my life and maybe give an example or
two but it's not like you feel you have
to convince the therapist
i want to be sure to let people know
that there are
lots of ways of getting good
psychotherapy at
a reduced fee so there are institutes
where people get advanced training
beyond their doctorate
and all those institutes have training
clinics
where people are treated at a low fee
and some people might think that the
higher the fee the more skilled the
practitioner
which is not necessarily the case
but certainly in that case it's not true
you